comme tous les jours ou presque julien
vient s'entraîner dans sa salle de sport
située à guyancourt pendant une à deux
heures ce sportif de 26 ans transpirent
pour sculpter son corps son objectif
être performant dans le culturisme au
bodybuilding en anglais un sport qu'il a
débuté à l'âge de 16 ans alors qu'il
faisait 60 kg en fait c'était à la base
un sport que je faisais vraiment injuste
pour les sculpter un corps me sentir
bien dans ma peau et avec le temps en
fait quand tu commences à prendre un
petit peu les habitudes quand tu
commences à y aller à des heures
régulières tu rencontres des gens les
mêmes gens régulièrement et de ce fait
en fait ça devient vraiment un endroit
un petit cocon où tu passes une heure
deux heures par jour et au final en fait
avec le temps tu continues à te
documenter à découvrir un petit peu ce
domaine là après dix ans de pratique
julien n'est plus au stade de
l'observation mais de la compétition
libinois participe à des concours
abatteurs espère un jour obtenir sa
carte professionnelle
pour atteindre cet objectif l'athlète
d'un mètre 77 pour cent kilos doit
convaincre sur scène un jury lors de ces
rendez vous ici dans sa catégorie les
observateurs évaluent le buste des
participants selon plusieurs critères
nous on est plus en fait homme de plage
donc c'est à dire on va avoir des
positions dites naturelles donc les
fidjiens ya quand même un travail
spécifique de la contraction mais on
essaie d'être le plus relâchée possible
et effectivement d'avoir une prestance
d'une aisance sur scène ce qui est plus
important d'avoir ce qu'on appelle le
posing et en fait on est jugé sur sa sur
la comme j'ai dit sur la symétrie sur la
masse musculaire mais également sur ce
qu'on va dégager sur scène c'est un peu
comme un ange envie de faire un concours
de miss france mais pour des mecs
musclés pour faire découvrir sa passion
au plus grand nombre julien sortir un
film sur son parcours dans le milieu du
bodybuilding un documentaire de 25
minutes projeté pour la première fois à
paris au mois de mars son objectif
combattre les clichés sur ces
disciplines moi aujourd'hui à mon petit
niveau à ma petite échelle j'essaye de
combattre ça justement faire comprendre
qu'on n'est pas tous des tout dans le
dans les bras dans le cerveau le but
c'est vraiment de se faire comprendre
que voilà on peut faire cette discipline
mais quelqu'un de normal aussi d'avoir
un business à côté de faire sa vie et
d'être quelqu'un d'intelligent parce que
voilà il faut savoir que malgré tout
faut quand même être cadré et
intelligent pour faire ce sport-là
julien va maintenant continuer à
sculpter son corps sur cette année 2022
avant de reprendre la compétition au
premier semestre 2023 avec toujours cet
objectif en tête passer professionnel